well we're actually retooling the whole
site it's a little bit like when you
want to rebuild the kitchen you have to
sort of demolish it first so we've been
in that process and will be relaunching
in January and part of the reason is
that there have been a lot of
developments online that we want to
capitalize on and that's involved the
necessity of building a new
infrastructure so the new site will have
much more opportunity for social
networking much more opportunities for
targeting and personalization it'll have
widgets so people can port their content
to other sites I think the days of kind
of the walled garden approach are really
in the past and it'll just have a much
more expansive opportunity for content
including a lot of video content which
we know from our own experience online
with our consumers is a growing interest
as more and more people have high-speed
broadband access